Well,
thank you all very much for coming.
Um,
I wrote this little book for the Aup series,
very short introductions.
And since then I've got very interested in the presence of stories in the
current times of dislocation and migration.
So there's an actual,
um,
angle to this talk which follows on from the definitions and discussion in the
book,
but is not quite exactly the same.
Um,
this,
this is a wonderful work.
You probably know her,
she's a,
she does these cutout sculptures from older books and um,
it seems to be this captured brilliantly the idea of the secrecy of the story,
the secrecy of the intimacy,
the hidden knowledge deep in the forest and the idea of the illumination that
the story might bring
one of the,
there are many,
many ways to approach a definition of fairytale,
but one of the interesting aspects of it is that it's frequently associated with
women's voices.
Now this may be to some extent derogatory because Plato,
for example,
as early as Plato,
he says,
oh,
those are just old wives tales.
So,
so the old wife,
the idea of the old wives' tale,
which is exactly what it is in Greek,
is a sense,
a story that is kind of what we call now fake news.
You know,
it's a kind of,
it's a sort of nostrum full of superstition and ignorance.
So very,
very early on there's this si the Stegall derogatory aspect and that may have
led to the association of such material fairytales,
fables.
It's a vast body of work that I'm going to stick to a fairytale.
Um,
this,
um,
it might lead to this assists association and attributing them,
you know,
we don't do it.
We Authority figures.
Don't do it.
There's old women do it.
But that's probably not the case.
It's probably also true that these were,
this was a body of stories circulating on the,
in,
in the,
in family and private circuits.
Because one characteristic of fairytales is that it's not associated with
literate elites.
Now,
that doesn't mean that it wasn't written down.
A lot of them are written down and I'll show you some very famous collectors.
But on the whole,
you didn't have to be somebody with an education to be able to pass on a version
of Cinderella.
And that means that it is actually the body of imaginative discovery and
creation that links us all together.
That numerous cultural variations,
many different aspects of societies are reflected.
If you are in a polygamous society,
you have stuck fairy tales about polygamy,
if you're in et cetera.
There's monsters take on the shape of local fairs and so forth.
But basically the structures are a form of language.
They are what I have called and Esperanto of the imagination.
We can talk to somebody from Finland or from Australia through the language of
fairytale.
One of the earliest fairytales written down is cupid and psyche,
which is a beauty and the beast story.
And it's interesting to be set up in the middle of a remarkable novel,
which some of you will know.
Um,
I pull Aaos is the golden asks,
which is about the transformation of Lucy as the hero into a donkey.
And as a donkey,
he experiences much stuff,
many sufferings,
the brutality of people,
but also a lot of comedy.
And then it ends with a religious initiation.
But in the middle of this story,
a young woman is abducted on her wedding night by bandits,
and she's taken to a cave.
Her husband is seized by the bandits and taken elsewhere and she fears for his
life,
quite rightfully.
Um,
and she's taken,
she's called character,
and she's taken by the bandage to their cave cave,
their lair,
and she's given into the keeping of a disreputable old woman at the disreputable
a woman when she's weeping and weeping because she has lost her husband and
she's been raped and abducted.
She,
um,
the old woman says,
let me tell you a story to make you feel a little better.
And this is absolutely to the heart.
I mean,
this is very early version of a fairytale in print.
This is,
goes to the heart of the,
of the characteristic defiance of the fairytale.
It's not exactly optimism.
The,
the happy ending is never elaborated.
The story of Crow quilting.
I'm kindness of infanticide and starvation and so forth.
And maltreatment will unfold fully occupying the story.
And then at the end it will be a promise that this will be changed.
So,
so it's an act of defiance more than an expression of how hope can take place.
It was that spirit,
that spirit of what Walter Benyamin called cunning and high spirits,
um,
flows through the conventional fairytale,
the traditional idea.
We have a fairytale,
I mean it differs it from a myth and myth will not necessarily come to a
conclusion that is hopeful or this defiant.
It will often be tragic and it differs from a ballot.
The ballot,
like the one you were hearing when you came in,
which is a very famous with numerous variations,
both verbal variations and musical variations that um,
there's no called binary in the Scottish tradition and that one is called the
two sisters.
Emily Portman was singing it.
And that's a story of two sisters who arrivals for the same man and one sister
kills the other one.
And then when the sister has she murders after she was murdered her,
she buries her,
her in the murder of a river bank.
And then someone coming by sees a bone sticking out of the,
of the mod,
thinks it's an animal burn and takes it out.
And it's either a pipe,
yeah,
that makes it into a pipe or he makes it into a harp from her breastbone.
And then he goes to play this minstrel.
This,
this shepherd who's found this,
this,
um,
it's made this instrument for himself,
goes to the king's hall and starts trying to play.
And the musical instrument will only play the song of the murder.
So when it's,
when,
when he pipes on it,
there's this pipe sings,
I was your sister,
you killed me.
And if it's a breast bone that's been strong for a harp,
the harp sings,
you have strongly my hair on your hub and then tells the story of her murder.
So there are,
so that is an example of a story that has,
you know,
no happy resolution.
It's just a sad,
except there's a revenge on the merger that otherwise it's not at all a happy
story.
Um,
but it is,
it belongs to fairytale.
In one sense.
It's supernatural.
And it's the idea of the eloquent bone,
which of course it's very central to the idea of the oral voice.
So that there are numerous examples in high literature,
um,
of this idea of the circle of storytellers.
And very frequently,
as I said,
female.
So here Boccaccio they're fleeing the plague and the women dominate the
storytelling scene.
So there you have a in Boccaccio who have a tremendous collection of wonderful,
inventive stories that have that again attributed to two women's passing on to
the traditions of exchanges between women.
Um,
the first famous collection that we all know that we all know because it
contains blue,
the Ed,
it contains Red Riding Hood.
It contains sleeping,
beauty is sharp,
the whole.
So here you have the example of what,
what very characteristic pattern,
which is that a man comes along who was highly educated.
He was a very high court official under Luke at herbs.
And He,
um,
he collected stories.
He said there were just so near to,
they were just a little trifles.
There were absurdities and Pertti collected them from his grandmother and his
servants.
And then he wrote them in these very arrogant,
very,
very arrogant French,
ironic,
a delightful,
sophisticated stories which have been retold and retold many,
many times in a different tone of voice.
He's much more feline and savvy and sort of knowing them then where we produce
these stories for children.
He had a contemporary,
oh,
so and so he,
and he signed the book mother goose.
So there you have an example of someone who is a,
you know,
a worldly Kocher taking on the identity of a poor old woman and a slightly
absurd figure.
Mother goose.
I'm numb,
no Hawaiian French.
Um,
and try and translate it translated into English culture almost directly.
We have still have mother goose collections,
mother goose books,
though he had a contemporary who was interestingly rather vanished as a name
from the history.
So mathy Catherine du Bois was a contemporary of pedals as I,
and she wrote many,
many,
many of fairytales turned into British pantomimes,
um,
like the golden goose.
Um,
the,
um,
trying to remember the one yellow dwarf these wall turned into Victorian
pantomimes and theater and film our chief conductors of this form of literature
at the same time.
And this is often forgotten because we think of unfortunately we are formed to
think of the Islamic world and the Christian world as kind of,
you know,
clove and apart somehow existing in separate spheres.
This was not at all the case.
They were deeply entangled.
And one of the ways they became very deeply entangled and our fairytale
tradition was interwoven with the um,
eastern oriental and Middle Eastern Fairytale tradition was through the Arabian
nights.
And then the immediate medieval year,
it was published in French first is the first print edition of this immense
collection of incredibly brilliant and elaborate stories of fantastic,
um,
rate range of range of human experiences,
which I'll tell you in a second about,
but um,
but that is,
you know,
it takes place as a storytelling seen in bed.
So,
the,
so the solution is killing all the women because he in his country because he
believes that all women are perfidious,
treacherous.
Adulterous is how you know him.
So he's decided to murder the mall and Shaharazad who's the daughter of his
vizier,
actually volunteers to,
um,
marry him on knowing that she's under threat,
that the following morning he will have her head cut off or show he'll have,
are strangled.
But she holds him by telling him stories.
And in the Arabian nights you have a clear picture of how stories were
associated with this.
Not only with this idea that you can make you feel a little better like the
bride and the cave,
but that you actually,
you could save your life.
And I think that that might seem preposterous,
but I think in our kind of very disruptive times and turbulent and hostile
times,
the function of stories matters more and more because they have this part
actually to impinge on reality and to,
and to change reality.
That the,
the frameworks of narrative through which we work,
uh,
more important than we've collapsed allowed.
It's not a frivolous side [inaudible] belong to the side,
um,
activity.
It's very central to human thought.
I mean I feel,
you know,
I'm speaking to an audience who knows this extraordinary well because the
Internet is,
it's in some sense an immaterial,
um,
expression of this network of stories and we're seeing a lot of the consequences
of people being frightened of that par.
And My,
my kind mission as a writer is to harness that par four for the ends of Justice
and equality and understanding and deeper intelligence and so forth rather than
for disinformation and propaganda and other uses,
which at the moment are gaining ground.
They don't necessarily need to gain ground,
but they are gaining ground.
Um,
there are three quotations which I just liked quickly to,
to mention to you.
One is Ursula Gwynn who unfortunately died as you know,
last year.
She says,
resistance and change often beginning art very often out.
She was,
she was addressing an audience of writers very often in our art,
the art of words as if she's making the same point.
There's a Harris out the storage.
Herzog is making that you can influence.
And shape the experience in reality through the power of words.
She never has.
Art tells many,
many varied stories across the gamut of very terrifying situations to the
Samsung.
And the ultimate aim is that he should see the error of his ways,
that he should see that there were other ways of responding to an adultery.
Then cutting off heads were women.
So the story eventually goes in full arc of 2001 nights,
uh,
to the resolution whereby he is a changed man.
Um,
unfortunately we know from the world that this has not happened because when I
was reading the Arabian nights very intensively,
I am,
it was the beginning of the war in Syria.
And,
um,
it was clear,
you know,
I sat,
it kept coming up in my mind as I,
as I read about the sultan who was so extreme and violent.
And,
um,
of course we know that have a muddy stories.
We tell us he doesn't change his views.
So there is a problem.
But the second quotation I wanted to mention too was Hannah Arendt,
who wrote an excellent book,
the human condition after the Second World War.
Stories are a form of action.
The way we insert ourselves into the human world.
And that the did,
she went on the ability to produce stories is the way we become historical.
She says produced stories,
but actually you can modify that to retail stories.
The way we take our traditions and refashioned them,
um,
makes a history.
It makes the history in which we are living.
And the third,
the third is,
is,
um,
it's from water venue mean in which he,
he,
he stresses that this,
these individual acts of telling stories are part of the community.
They're part of a collectivity.
And he to writing at the end of the Second World War,
um,
said every morning brings us the news of the globe.
And yet we are poor in noteworthy stories.
And he went on saying,
calling for the eye for more,
more speculative fiction that would build an experience in this,
in this sort of mayhem of the aftermath of the war.
Um,
folk art and the worldview of the child demand to be seen as collectivist ways
of thinking.
And I was very interested that you have such an emphasis on play in your
reception area.
Um,
because it seems to me that that connects quite both of anyone was very,
very interested in play and wrote wonderful things,
wonderful stories for the radio,
for children.
And this,
this,
there is a connection there that there is something about the fairytale that is
connected to the idea of the imagination at play.
You're not tied to the objective representation of reality.
You are speculative and we move freely with,
within this Esperanto of fantasy to in order to build possible possible
alternative worlds.
Okay.
So,
um,
the,
uh,
that's,
this is the Arabian nights were disseminated throughout the world and hundreds
of different versions and variations and this and been in the English and
French.
And then finally in Arabic they came into print in Arabic in the 19th century.
So,
um,
these are just a box you'll see there.
The Grimm brothers,
um,
they were the major collectors of the other famous stories that,
you know,
um,
Hansel and Gretel.
Um,
anyway,
we'll,
we'll look at them at the moment.
So,
um,
and they've dominated the scene and they brought,
but they did the cells invoke female or a female sources and when they came into
English,
so this is their,
one of their principle sources.
Very,
very nice.
A portrait about the younger brother who didn't collect stories but was an
artist of that,
one of their principle sources of fairytales.
She knew very many of them.
Then,
um,
when they were translated into English,
they interestingly,
the English were anxious about the cruelty.
So George Cruickshank who was a cartoonist and a current campaign,
or actually he was a teetotaler.
And so when he,
when he rewrote translated Cinderella in the grim version,
he had the fountains at the wedding flow with lemonade because he wanted to make
sure that he was chair campaigning.
I got drunk from listen in England.
But the emphasis in England try to shift it to comedy.
And you can see that in this front of space,
they sort of the,
the stories become Julia and more,
more kind of cheerful and,
and more absurd that there's a,
there's a desire to pull away,
which has not come back actually versed.
We now in our back with cruelty and violence.
People now acknowledge strongly that that's,
uh,
that's,
various various intrinsic part of the fairytale tradition.
Um,
the Cinderella the Grimm brothers collected is the one where he's ugly.
Sister's cut off their heels and cut off the toes to fit into the glass slipper.
And the prince realizes that it's not the right bride because there's blood in
the shoe was very bloody.
And then at the end,
the enchanted birds pick out the eyes of the sisters at the wedding Cinderellas
wedding.
So they're both maimed and their feet and blinded in their own.
Um,
very happy.
They're happy ending,
very happy ending that,
that the,
that has an interesting um,
um,
little Coda,
which is that they collected it from the poor house in Marburg.
There were students at marble.
They began when they were very young collecting stories.
So there were students at Marburg University and they heard that there was a old
woman in the arms house.
I in the poor house who knew a lot of stories and they asked to see her and to
collect her stories and she didn't want to see them.
She refused.
So they paired the daughter of the Arms House director,
they gave her a little,
I mean,
not the tiny,
which was with go and an asset to how,
you know,
you go in and ask her to tell you a story and then you come up,
tell it to us and we'll write it down.
And the little girl did this and this is the Cinderella she told.
And My,
my feeling,
my interpretation of this is that the old woman in the arms house was passing on
a female secret of very,
very cruel version of revenge amongst swimming.
And she didn't want the fine gentleman from the university to know this kind of
story.
It was a,
it was a kind of promise between women,
between generations of women,
you know,
that if you're,
if you're badly treated,
you will escape and there will be a wonderful revenge.
And,
um,
so it's an interesting example.
We didn't have many actual scenes of that car.
We don't know the exact circumstances of a lot of collecting.
And there's a lot of,
of course massaging and changing of the sources.
Even the grims pretended to be setting it down verbatim,
but they couldn't,
they kept rewriting them cause we have the drafts.
Okay.
So one of the,
um,
there,
there are many definitions of fairytales that I can't go into here.
One of them is obviously the president.
There's a presence of the supernatural.
Now that's a very important and you know,
defining characteristic,
the enchantment of the supernatural.
But there is a way in which the supernatural is there because reality can't be
tolerated.
It can't be born.
It is on so on bearable because the real heart of fairytale content is
suffering.
It's a domain of pain.
Um,
you have then every kind of human aberration crime
ordeal are,
are represented that in spite of their supernatural clothing,
the enchantments,
the improbabilities,
the actually very close to real experience.
So for example,
this donkey skin,
I don't know if any of you know it,
it's the one that's most least reproduced from [inaudible] collection because
it's about father,
daughter incest.
And so in the story,
her father wants to marry her after the death of her mother because she looks
just like her mother and he's promised never to marry again unless somebody was
as good as her mother.
So he,
so he asked to marry her.
She doesn't want to marry her Farber.
And there's a lot of magic to help her.
And the One and part of the magic is that she's given a kind of magic donkey
skin.
Um,
and this is her in that disguise.
And then she takes the job as a scallion in the kitchen.
She flees her father.
And interestingly,
the story in its this rather lighthearted,
they're written by people.
The story upholds the girl against her father.
So here you have a story of filial disobedience.
She refuses to marry her father as he asks her to do that,
is that the story is fully not,
not currently,
is overtly upholding.
The story is on her side.
She's every,
that it is the wrong thing for him to ask.
So this story,
if you imagine it being passed on,
is a way in which the customs of the tribe are being communicated without
actually telling a story of child abuse.
I mean,
this is,
it's very fanciful.
It feels they can,
it's once upon a time,
far away in a great palace,
a king,
you know,
et cetera.
So it sort of distanced by the act of literature,
literary imagination,
but at the same time,
it's carries this seed.
They're very important seed.
I mean,
if you could imagine how different it would be if the child abuse stories were
told in this way,
we would understand.
I mean,
it's in a way,
or lack of them that has made cook recall some of the difficulties that we're
experiencing today.
Children,
if they were bought up with lots of fairytales about Harvey Weinstein in
disguise as a king,
they would have more of a understanding.
Um,
instead of being constantly promoted by the tabloids into being beautiful for,
to please and so forth.
So it's,
um,
it's,
uh,
this is a great loss start of,
um,
I mean it's,
it's coming back.
It's coming back,
but it's to some extent the lost art of communication.
Um,
it was made into a wonderful film in 1970 a badge academia with Katherine's,
a nerve in the row.
And I wanted to put this in not only to remind you what a great film this is,
but also that film is probably one of the ways that most of you have encountered
fairytales.
It's the chief channel of communication for four,
four s even,
even for children,
they're not really read fairytale so much.
Uh,
seeing them because of this being this language of Esperanto,
Esperanto language,
the big blockbuster studios love it because it can actually communicate across
cultures.
Okay.
So,
um,
Cinderella is about stepmothers the same pos CEP,
CEP mother role is in some languages the same as the mother in law,
same word.
So bell may have in French means stepmother and mother-in-law.
That's quite common in civil societies.
So the situation that Cinderella is in of being turned into a so skivi and
abused and not given food very,
very widespread in many,
many cultures that the,
the either the unwanted child of an earlier marriage or the daughter in law is
turned into a servant.
So this again in the heart of this fanciful tear them enchantment lie is a very
true,
a true representation.
Um,
we're very imprinted by the film tradition.
and I'm sure many of you,
probably all of you have seen snow white and he's incredibly early.
I think 1937.
It's a,
it's,
I mean he,
he,
he used the medium early on.
Um,
and there's another here,
there's another couch is a couch,
which is that this evil stepmother figure we can perhaps you could ask me about
it later cause they weren't blinker now and has become an architect and
archetypes.
And here the reality,
uh,
flips over in the sense that a lot of stepmothers today from there aren't very
many,
many because of easier divorce,
um,
are um,
much I really very well meaning and long to be loved by their stepchildren and
don't know,
treat them at all.
But the children have all seen Disney and,
and so there you have the kind of,
the reflection of reality in the store is from a different era impinging and
passing on,
reflecting on the reality of experience in the present with it with a dangerous
effect.
So this,
and this means that the fairy tales need constantly to be rewritten and re re
reworked the maleficent,
the sleeping beauty that was recently done,
did a very interesting reworking,
which we can talk about again,
data.
This was a pub,
a superb,
smooth white,
which took on a Disney directly.
It didn't do anything kind of Glib like reverse the step stepmother figure,
but it crit made snow white herself so interesting and so appealing and so
beautiful,
but it didn't have a happy ending.
The film does not have a happy ending.
So it's an example of how the new reworkings and re recreation's of classic
fairytales actually often edge them into myth and edge them into tragedy.
Hansel and Gretel,
probably one of the most famous stories in the world,
um,
is about child abandonment due to starvation.
And that is a very,
very common um,
predicament.
And not only in the past,
quite a lot of the refugees arriving in Europe,
I've are exactly in the situation.
They're not as,
not exactly infanticide in the story.
It says that we will leave them to die.
That actually what happened in the past,
in the early modern period and probably before that and it's happening now and
some of the war torn areas is that families are saying,
leave.
We're going to let you leave.
We're going to put you on the boat.
You'll probably read many of these refugee stories.
We take you to the front here.
You're nine years old,
we take you to the front sheet,
we're going to leave you there because they will come and they will help you.
So there's this sort of modern version of infanticide,
which is we're just sending children into a place to a place where they might be
safer and have something to eat and have something some worse.
They don't have what in the place they are.
Um,
uh,
there's a wonderful,
wonderful illustrations that David Hockney did.
Um,
the children being cooked for supper,
again,
aspect of famine,
famine,
being Italian,
being one of the dominant spurs to the sufferings reflected in fairytales.
Um,
Angela Carter wants to at a very famous thing,
she said,
um,
I'm a fairytale.
The definition of a fairytale is a story in which one king goes to another king
to borrow a cup of sugar
farming.
Only the kings have sugar.
So,
um,
some kings have sugar.
So this I'm here,
he's being mischievous with Rapunzel.
Rapunzel is a story about a woman who,
a childless woman who takes the new baby of the couple who live next door.
And again,
this is some,
this is actually a story which I wrote a short,
I was inspired to write a short story from the point of view of the witch
because,
um,
it seemed to me that it was very much about childlessness and adoption.
We,
she adopts Ripon,
she adopts Rapunzel and then she wants to keep her really safe.
And then the prince comes by and you'll probably know the story and climbs up
her hair.
And then one day she says to the old witch who looks after her,
she says,
you know,
why am I close getting a little tight?
And the old witch,
you know,
loses her temper,
realizes that someone has been get again and uh,
and that Rapunzel is having a baby and she beats her and abuser.
So it cuts off her hair at that,
of course,
was cleaned up.
Originally it was the grims couldn't bear the fact that a Rapunzel was pregnant.
So then they just had,
um,
have be say something completely different,
which makes a nonsense of the story that the story is about as a protection of a
woman who didn't have a child.
And has adopted a child.
And that seemed to me to be incredibly record recognizable as a contemporary
experience.
So that's when other,
that's one of the images rack.
And one we had them tastic tradition of,
of um,
illustrators in this country,
including Arthur Rackham,
water,
Korean,
another one,
um,
the,
the body,
the beauty and the beast corpus of stories,
which comes down from cupid and psyche pretty directly,
um,
are,
is the vehicle of an enormous number of explorations of the state of marriage to
a brute.
So the,
and the hope that it's held art in beauty and the beast is that with love and
time,
the brute will turn into a wonderful and lovable husband.
The story as we know it best of all,
which is this version was written by our governors here in England,
in French.
She was a French governess for her charges,
who all in arranged marriages.
So it's,
uh,
it's,
it's a story that comes out of the arranged marriage in which you will,
you know,
find a stranger who you have to marry.
And um,
and it was trust.
That is all we well,
but of course some versions if not all as well.
And there's that slight Bluebeard,
the blue bear dessert.
Another classic classic story that looks at the inside of a,
of an abusive marriage.
The um,
in the Arabian nights opens with a very interesting example of a storyteller
thinking about conditions in the world.
Um,
so the two kings who you see up hidden in the tree and have both found their
wives supposedly to cavorting with slaves and having sex with them in a very
raunchy and extreme fashion.
The book is quite explicit,
not for children,
but the original.
Um,
and so they both decided WWE world is not for them.
This is a disgusting.
They killed with their wives and then they decided the world is not for them and
they go wandering across the world and they come across [inaudible] out of the
sea comes a vast gin.
And on his head he's carrying a glass casket in which there is the body of a
beautiful young girl,
naked body of a beautiful young girl.
And she again,
it turns out there's been abducted on her wedding night.
It's interesting,
these,
these motifs recur.
And also you'll notice the glass box,
which of course gets into Snow White.
So,
um,
so this glass coffin,
which she is still alive,
and he,
he lets her out and the king's climb a tree to hide from it,
from the scare of this gin and the gin falls asleep.
And when he's asleep,
she solicits the king's she's noticed them in the tree and she solicits the
kings and beckons them down and then orders them to make love to her.
And they say,
no,
absolutely.
We're not that kind of person.
And,
um,
and she insists,
she says,
if you don't,
I will murder.
I will raise the gym and he runs our wake him up and he will kill you.
So they agree very reluctantly.
And um,
and then,
um,
after they've both done the evil deed,
she takes out of her clothes,
a string of rings,
and she demands that they give her a ring as a pledge of her,
the,
of what's just happened.
And,
um,
and they said no,
they weren't.
And she says,
well,
I wake up the gin.
So they give her the rings and when she puts them on the string in the English
version,
that makes her 98 rings so far into a hundred.
And in the Arabic version she's got 365.
So that was censored in the English translation
was reduced.
Um,
so,
um,
the interestingly one of the scholars of this story,
the obvious sort of the surface of the story is rather than the sojourner east,
you know,
here's this lascivious.
This is a severe as woman who demand sex and Dune as having the,
taking this revenge in this list.
You know,
she's sort of uncontrolled and she fulfills in the story or the worst imaginings
of the two kings who have seen their adulterous wives.
They now say we're all women are like that.
So they go back home and then that's when they start killing or women.
So it's,
it's presented as women's Wilders,
but actually what,
it's what's happened in,
you're going into or center of the story that is telling you what will happen if
you do wrong.
If you take a woman from her wedding and try to an abductor and keep her in a
glass box,
women will not obey that.
They will not submit.
And this is,
this is a fundamental wrong and it,
and you will suffer for it.
You will,
there will be a consequence.
So while it's put into sort of fairytale setting,
it has actually a carnal of thinking about justice in it.
Especially if you imagine this,
the beginning of the story in which we're going to hear many,
many,
many stories in which at the end the king will realize that he's come to the
false conclusions and he must mended his ways.
All right.
One of the other important aspects of fairytales that I,
I've become increasingly interested in is,
is that portability.
They seem to transcend difficulties of translation.
This is a very,
very mysterious process.
I mean,
there are trade routes,
there are,
um,
there are traveling scholars,
there are traveling missionaries,
there are traveling voices that possibly translate the stories.
But at the same time,
it seems more fundamental than that in that the sort of desire,
the human desire to make stories and transmit them and hear them overcomes
cultural barriers in a very real,
very,
very remarkable way.
So we have stories like the epic of Gilgamesh,
which is one of the,
is probably the earliest extent a store imaginative piece of literature.
We have it written down in 800 BC,
but it's much,
much older in,
um,
in,
in a,
in actual creation.
And it's,
um,
and many,
many of its elements.
It's a fantastic book,
which was telling me she read when she was studying.
Um,
it's a fantastic and exciting and wonderful,
wonderful poem,
full of deep human scenes of loss and love and exploration and power,
everything.
Um,
it's elements.
It was only found in the mid 19th century in the desert,
in the library of Ashwood,
Avanti power in Nineveh.
So it actually was only read,
um,
then,
so it's like a modern book for 2000 years.
It wasn't red
burst on the scene and many things in it were recognizable because the elements
of the story had traveled.
So,
for example,
there's one whole cycle of stories within the Arabian Nights,
which is very close to Gilgamesh,
in which the hero goes down to the bottom of the seat of a cup to pick the plant
of in mortality.
Um,
and other many other aspects and why the Victorians loved it,
was that it can tell you the story of the flood.
It contains the story of Noah.
He's got a different name,
but it's the same story.
And they thought because they were Christians,
they thought,
oh,
this proves the truth of the flood because we have another source for it.
But actually what it proves is that stories,
stories circulate the past.
They'd pass.
This is,
uh,
the British Museum is full of these absolutely wonderful miniature stories,
that wonderful form,
which I would love to use myself in which you,
this is,
you know,
you roll this on wax.
So it's the stories in sized intuition.
Then you read it on wax and you get the freeze like that.
Um,
an example of another enormous body of fairytales,
northern Scandinavian.
This became the ring of the limbo then was sort of Icelandic sagas Norwegian
Sargus got in,
became the Wagner and the ring cycle,
huge living body of myth that then gives us talky talky in as you know,
such a incredible success as a film that that New Zealand has now got.
Most of this is highest proportion of GNP comes from it's CGI industries.
That was driven by the fact that the director decided to film Tolkien in New
Zealand.
So that's a,
that's another different sort of example of the material effect of fantasy and
fairytale.
Um,
the,
the crossing point,
the important of crossing point between East and west.
It was the Mediterranean and the island of Sicily,
which for a while was in under an Arab rule.
And then change to Norman rule,
the same Norman family that conquered Britain.
And,
um,
and we have one collection.
This is another body of fairytales that proverbial,
which are animal fables.
So when you say once water never makes a summer or a dog in the manger or many,
many other proverbial phrases that use animals as the reflect humans.
They all come from AESOP's fables and AESOP's fables have an earlier version in
India and,
and they get into this Arabic book written in Sicily in the 12th century where
he expresses it as being between women telling stories and they,
um,
but it's,
and he makes variations.
They're not the same as the engine story is no other,
the same as Aesop's fables,
but they have jackals and king jackals and lions and um,
you know,
snakes,
donkeys,
all the to carry all that vast cast of characters,
animal characters that then gets into the lion king and two into much of popular
term.
This is the,
the ballad that I played.
So that's some,
because we played at the beginning and Angela Carter does a variation on that.
I thought when I was teaching at fairytales,
my students all wanted to know about lunch.
Ricotta,
us,
I don't know if you want to know about her,
but half have wonderful story.
The Earl king in the bloody chamber is based on this tour story of the two
sisters that,
um,
and the Earl king and her version.
She's put the stories together.
The Earl king and her version turns all his victims into singing birds and then
she has to rescue them.
The narrator.
All right,
so this is the coder,
um,
this idea of stories as habitat as the place you,
you'd dwell,
the place that you create,
where you dwell,
the way you furnish your imagination and use it to apprehend and engage with the
world through the,
through the narratives that you have,
a structure and that this could form,
could form a sanctuary.
There was one very nice example of it in this,
this man's book.
He was a,
became a very prominent,
the tree critique in Germany,
but he was in the Po,
in the ghetto in Warsaw,
um,
as a young man.
And he just got married and he and his wife fled,
managed to get out of the ghetto before the massacres.
And they were hidden by two Protestant Germans in their cellar,
the Protestant,
the Protestants were out of work.
It was very about times.
It's very difficult to eat,
um,
during the war.
And they'd,
but they didn't shelter the,
to Jews for reasons of benevolence.
They shuttered them because they enslaved them.
They made them roll cigarettes for the contraband of traffic in cigarettes.
So they would in the dark and the seller,
um,
and very much at the mercy,
very frightened.
Any moment there would be denounced that it would not in the end be worth the
while of their shelters to keep them and feed them in return for what they got
for their,
and I'm the,
one day the woman came down and she said,
I'm so bored I could scream.
And this man in his twenties,
Marcel decided that he would tell her a story and he ransacked his mind to
everything he'd ever read.
Every film you've ever seen,
every opera plots he'd ever heard about,
every,
every sort of nursery rhyme,
absolutely everything.
And the,
the,
the atmosphere completely changed.
They became very dependent on hearing more stories.
And,
um,
and then by the end of the war,
they were,
I mean,
they will not denounced.
They were,
the end of the war came and made great hardship and the um,
and though they would not exactly sort of best of friends,
they were definitely on terms that were different from the terms that the
Germans and the Jewish victims had been on before.
He told them the plot of Aida was this most extraordinary,
not an example of them.
I think he must've been very good at it,
um,
because it's not always,
it must be very good at remembering too.
Um,
so I think that the,
the concept of sanctuary was a legal,
Alice is a lawyer.
I didn't know if she knows about the deagle 30,000 years.
There was a concept of sanctuary in this country.
You could,
until Henry the eighth abolished it,
you could establish a place that was a safe place.
It was not an armed place.
It had no fence or,
or lock.
It was simply a symbolic place that was created by the decree of words.
So you see the place was designated by custom tradition and language as the
sanctuary.
So this is an example.
It's still exist.
And you'll notice that it has on it this monstrous face.
And they frequently sanctuaries sanctuary places such as still survive if that's
another one that doesn't have a monster,
but they often have like the door knockers of sanctuary buildings have a
monstrous face on them.
And I think the connections is another one in Norridge.
And this is a famous one in Durham.
And um,
and I think the connection is that it connects to the fundamental recognition
that the patent patent words have what's technically called performative par.
They will institute,
they can institute something like a safe place.
And I think that's forms that that presents an analogy for what stories can do.
They can demarcate a space in which you are free to do certain things like
imagine delicious revenge is or,
um,
or reparations or redress that you are still held safely within it.
It's not going to be,
it's not going to endanger you.
This speech,
the speech of imagination is not quite the same as direct communication.
And the other thing is that words have efficacy as in institute reality.
This is something that obviously this is partly magical thinking and a lot of
people descend from it,
but it's something that I have sort of pretty much come to acknowledge and
accept and even support,
um,
throughout my work,
which began with looking at religious symbols,
which certainly have this par.
And,
um,
and now we're looking at secular,
secular storytelling.
So we s I started,
this is the end.
I started a project in Sicily with the,
with the,
um,
refugees there because Sicily is this crossing point right here is a map of the,
from the sixth,
17th century sharing consistency right in the middle of the Mediterranean.
Um,
they all,
they all arrive there 600,000 and the last two years.
And one of the problems of the,
uh,
you know,
we were talking about traveling stories and how they leap cultural barriers,
but actually how do we tell a story of someone who doesn't know your language?
So we wanted to just to find a way of creating stories for imagination,
not their own stories,
not their testimony.
There are different kinds of story.
Two stories.
They might remember themselves from that amount,
from the cup,
from their culture stories.
They want to invent themselves now and how are we going to do it.
And of course the city has a tremendous tradition of puppetry.
And so the w there are many languages beyond language that are communicative.
So there's puppetry,
there's music,
there's um,
a gesture dance.
And so we've working with puppets.
Um,
this is the puppet theater,
traditional puppet theater in Palermo.
Here they are learning and the puppets,
the only you they took to it,
they really loved it.
We do dancing,
ask them how they dance in their countries.
Um,
we do group group,
um,
this,
this is sort of word game as it comes around to you.
The ball as you throw the ball and make this web you,
you say a word and I would as part of the story or I mean you give a structure
ahead of time and then,
and that works also rather well.
Um,
and um,
so he has a group session on sound making sounds.
And this was,
this is part of the Gilgamesh workshop.
So here they're making the sounds of the city of work,
um,
as a sort of chorus.
So they did bird songs and you know,
animal sounds and not exactly a traffic signs because they wouldn't have been so
much traffic in the end.
But,
um,
and here is I think Gilgamesh,
that's his visor.
Yes.
That's the sort of beginning of the Gilgamesh puppet.
And here they are doing an animation.
We took an animator with us and they really loved this.
This isn't to do animation on your phone and they really,
really liked doing that.
Here are three of the characters.
Um,
if,
you know,
if you know the epic,
that story,
the innkeeper,
the tavern keeper on the road,
um,
I think we inky do in the middle.
That's the plan to mortality.
We made it with balloons and here's,
here's another Gilgamesh or different Gilgamesh.
Um,
and so we got a very good write up in the local paper,
which we were very pleased with.
So,
um,
so this was an idea of taking,
really of conforming to my ideas about the transmission and the freedom of the
language of stories and trying to adapt it to a present day,
a crisis of young people arriving.
I'm hoping to make a better world for themselves and for us too.
Thank you.
It's also for the question,
um,
you talked about the Cinderella story and how that was given to a young girl by
a woman.
Um,
and so obviously we received the stories quite differently.
Now we see them on mass one film.
How does that change the way we received a story when we're not getting it?
Women's women or father to son?
Well,
there has been a returner shear to women's presence in the fairytale
transmission.
Um,
I mean the maleficent was produced by Angelina Jolie and the scriptures I think
by Linda Woolverton who did beauty and the beast as well.
So there's been a recognition within the industry that actually,
and it's not just for,
you know,
reasons of the women are coming up.
It's actually the women being identified with the genre and wishing to rewrite
it themselves in order to,
in order to transform it.
I mean,
I was pleased with it.
I have some men in the audience because normally when I speak about fairytales,
it's almost always women.
There's a very strong feeling for the relationship,
the fairytales and women knows Paul is it,
it's one of the main,
the tree bodies of work in which women feature prominently meet the characters,
the prince characters,
often various sort of not very colorful and her mother dim.
So there's more interest in the women's characters.
Even the,
even the malignant women,
it was a real,
in the same way as in Greek myths to this,
women are attracted to the Greek myths because they're full of women,
full of full of different scenarios around women.
I mean the deer is a great favorite now with women directors and actors.
So,
um,
so,
but your other,
the other aspect of his lip sort of in a sense less.
There's positive and it says it's also a problem with the web.
And that is that there's a sort of homogenization because you're not speaking in
particular to a group of speaking more widely.
So you need to please kind of too many people,
um,
or to please a particular group with art actually troubling them.
So that's,
I mean there's a,
the,
the audience,
the mass audience is,
it creates,
um,
yes,
a difference of specificity.
There's this visitor out of variant,
a donkey,
donkey skin variant,
and which actually puts this choses quite clearly,
which is,
it was collected by an anthropologist from a very poor part of Spain as from my
daughter and in the donkey skin.
That version,
she doesn't wear a donkey skin.
She wears a Pelican skin and he couldn't,
he couldn't understand why this heroin is,
it has guys as a Pelican
because there are absolutely no Pelicans in Spain.
And then he,
when he went there to do is wait.
I mean,
he realized that the endemic illness in the area,
it was goiter.
So in the story she is loved in spite of being a donkey looking or wearing a
smelly,
horrible,
filthy donkey skin.
The prince recognizes her true beauty underneath her disguise.
And in Extremadura this Pelican does guys to go is also recognizing the story
for her beauty and goodness beneath her doll helicon skin,
which of course is standing in for the illness of goiter
in that particular area.
It wouldn't work if you put it in a film because it wouldn't make the same s
particular sense.
I think you began to touch on it just now already,
but how is the kind of myths and legends,
are they seen as separate to fairy tales?
Are they seen as sort of the male power,
the more domestic,
very tailored shoes?
How did they get there are,
yes.
I mean one of the main difference there obviously overlaps.
And as I said,
I think that there's a tendency now trend,
the fairytale mode is moved,
becoming more mythical.
But um,
the,
one of the main differences is that the characters in fairytales are humans with
some magic.
They're not gods.
So,
so,
and the other is that while there were some people in different cultures who
believe in some of the supernatural elements in fairytales on the whole,
they are not connected to official religion.
I mean that's a fairly,
it's a rule of thumb.
I mean the gin are in the Koran,
so the gin are actually,
it should be believed,
whereas the Ferris are not in the Bible.
So we didn't have to believe in them according to doctrine.
But there have been communities that certainly believed in fairies and still do
probably.
But,
um,
I mean I think there are quite a lot like,
which is sort of coming back.
People believe in them.
So it's,
um,
you know,
there are aspects that are connected to real belief,
but on the whole,
the fairytale,
it is a space of unbelief.
It's a space of imagination.
It does not,
you're not requested to consent to it structures.
That's pretty different.
I mean,
we,
with myths,
with Greek myths,
we don't consent to the Olympians anymore,
but we do,
um,
where they did in the past.
I,
I if I understood you right,
I think you said earlier that we were,
we had for a period lost the ability to tell a fairy tales or to create new
fairytales,
but it was coming back.
I was just wondering if you could tell us why you thought that was.
Yeah.
Well,
the one is,
it's very complicated and difficult to understand because the romantics were
very interested in fairytales.
I mean the,
the lyrical ballads was with encourage contains it's poems there route because
we had collected some of the oral traditions that in Scotland and so forth.
So,
um,
if you think of a famous poem like I build done some EFC in which the night is
purely loitering and meets a ferry by via lake who kisses him and takes him into
a world.
I mean,
this is a fairytale.
So that's actually the same time the fairytales began falling down the ladder of
esteem and became associated with children.
It was partly an effect of the market because we,
there was a rise in Chuuk child,
children who could read the rise of the bourgeoisie in Victorian England meant
more children could read.
And there was a market and some of those beautiful books that were made were
made for children in each children who could,
parents could afford these nice books.
So it,
but that put it into a kind of niche.
And in that niche was the romantic idea that the imagination was the property of
the child.
You know,
when was with wrote,
not an entire forgetfulness and not in that nakedness,
but trailing clouds of glory.
Do we come to a child as a sort of marvelous creatures,
full of connections to other worlds and imagination.
But that made it childish.
And also we were very strongly then,
uh,
sort of encouraged or enjoined not to yield a fantasy and imagination that we as
adults should be rational and we should be objective and we should assess
evidence.
You know,
all this stuff about Fernandez and things was nonsense and it's any fit for
children.
So it fell under a huge kind of cloud of incomprehension because you don't have
to think of this as it's,
it's a,
it's a way of thinking,
you know,
thinking with the imagination is we're thinking it's not to be dismissed.
It's probably essential.
It's probably inevitable.
There's also essential because you can't really,
you have to model thought.
I mean,
they've now discovered with lots of cognitive studies that the imagination is
not separate from reason in the brain.
The,
the,
the synopsys same synopsys far.
If I say to you,
lady,
you know,
um,
what is the wonderful line?
A Unicorn sat under a juniper tree.
If I say a lady,
a lady with a unicorn sat under a juniper tree,
you bring it up in your mind's eye and you,
when you're doing that is the same as if I say to you,
I met your mother last week.
Your mother comes up in your mind's eye and you assemble it with me,
your mind.
Then you're using the same faculties.
There's the thought,
same place.
Fars so,
so,
so thinking models,
models,
thought using imaginative pars,
they're looking,
I think that's really interesting.
So you think maybe the invention of childhood in the Georgian than Victorian
periods,
mother,
we can pop Cobham at compartmentalize different kinds of stories as belonging to
different kinds of imaginative domains.
But,
but why then a fairy for is coming back?
Is it something to do with adults reclaiming childhood for themselves?
Well,
there is a lot of,
I mean there's been a lot of very,
very powerful work on play.
I mean,
when it cooked root,
you know,
very powerfully on the important,
I mean the development of children and the capacity to play in order for them to
become fully achieved adults has been,
has been a cornerstone of Piaget of winter coat of,
of about a new client.
Um,
and I don't think people who've ever turned out at all,
no.
Adam Phillips has written about this very important day.
I mean,
and do I think,
you know,
you have this ethos here because in order to sync the sync up the projects that,
Muse,
new thinking requires play.
You can't just stick to what's already known.
So it's that some,
so I think there's been a,
yes,
there's been a recuperation,
the re re evaluation,
evaluation of fantasy and imagination.
They're slightly different.
But nevertheless,
it's the to a contiguous contingent.
And,
um,
and uh,
but the attendant dangers,
I mean,
the people who insist on objectivity and so forth,
um,
you know,
they have identified a danger,
which is we can't live in Italian
imagination.
There's one exact thing just protested.
But
I mean,
just the great task of our time is to have,
is to how to
spa people to question what's the imagine and what they think,
but not by using only the tea,
the realistic of objective verification.
Because that will just trap us in what we already know.
Thank you very much.